gta 6 could arrive earlier than expected
the hitman trilogy is coming to game
pass and more
according to reports grand theft auto 6
is in development and might have a
fortnite style evolving map but when
might the long-awaited game be released
according to one analyst's prediction
the next entry in rockstar's popular
series might be in the works for 2023 or
2024. take two which owns rockstar said
in its zynga acquisition announcement
this week that it would have a compound
annual growth rate of 14
through 2024 an analyst at the research
company jefferies told axios there are
only a handful of titles that have the
power to give take two confidence it
could reach that and one is believed to
be a rockstar game doug krutz of cohen
and company said this points to a likely
gta 6 launch in the fiscal year of 24.
take two's fiscal year 24 runs from
april 1 2023 through march 31st 2024 so
the suggestion is that gta 6 would be
released sometime in that period other
reports have suggested gta 6 might not
be released until 2025.
in 2021 kotaku reported that rockstar
games had begun work on its next game a
new entry in the gta series however
rockstar games has not confirmed this
for more on gta 6 check out our roundup
of all the big rumors on gamespot.com
the hitman trilogy which includes three
games in the world of assassination
series will come to xbox game pass on
january 20th io interactive announced
today as part of the company's year 2
reveal we're excited to welcome a wave
of new players to enjoy the full trilogy
through new platforms and services io
said in a post now that the trilogy is
complete we're excited to unveil hitman
trilogy as a way for new players to get
started in the world of assassination
this collection brings together hitman
hitman 2 and hitman 3 into a single
package making it easier than ever to
take your first steps to becoming agent
47 the developer said
the hitman trilogy was revealed as a
part of io's wide announcements about
the future of hitman 3 as it enters its
second year the studio has big plans to
support the game with technical
improvements hitman vr on pc which looks
surprisingly action oriented and a new
single-player mode called hitman
freelancer which introduces roguelike
elements strategic planning and a
customizable safe house and this is just
to name a few of the new additions
it's not unusual for manufacturing on
consoles to cease after a new generation
of hardware arrives before the xbox one
its end came much sooner microsoft
discontinued production on the xbox one
s and xbox one x just before the launch
of the xbox series x and s consoles
allowing for retailers to finish selling
any remaining stock from the last gen
devices senior director of xbox console
product marketing cindy walker confirmed
to the verge that to focus on production
of xbox series x and s we stopped
production for all xbox one consoles by
the end of 2020. in comparison to
microsoft nintendo only discontinued its
3ds console manufacturing 3 years after
the switch launched while sony still
plans to produce around a million ps4
consoles in 2022 while both console
companies face a supply and demand
challenge due to an ongoing shortage of
vital chips for their machines microsoft
is confident that it can at least meet
demand for its xbox series s consoles
the 300 alternative for users who aren't
ready to go full current gen just yet
that console's more affordable price
point and modest internal hardware has
made it a more viable option when
compared to older and similarly priced
xbox one consoles especially when its
ssd storage is taken into consideration
and speaking of things being
discontinued let's all say a small
prayer for the halo 3 servers which have
gone down on the xbox 360 truly marking
the end of an era what are your favorite
halo 3 memories go ahead and let me know
in the comments below and of course
leave a like subscribe and tune in
tomorrow for your next episode of
gamespot news we'll catch you next time
[Music]
you